Oh, hallo Wolfgang.
Hallo Stefan.
Wo sind wir hier?
Ich habe selbstverständlich erstmal eine technische Frage an dich. Wie kann ich auf Facebook, Twitter und Instagram oberarme muten? Gibt es da eine Möglichkeit und du ahnst warum ich das frage?
Nein, ich weiß es nicht. Ich könnte dir aber empfehlen, so langsam vom Thema Influencer abzulassen und dich im Internet wieder den Guten erinnern.
Ja, das war ja jetzt etwas, was mich hier diese Woche nochmal so besonders erwischt hat in der Timeline bei Twitter vor allem. Und wir wissen, wer bei Twitter ist, da sind nicht die Influencer, da sind unsere Journalisten. Und in manchen Bundesländern gibt es ja jetzt verrückterweise eine Journalistenprio, dass die jetzt auch vorher geimpft werden sollen. Man fragt sich, warum. Das ist ja in meinen Augen vollkommener Unsinn. Aber offenbar haben sich da Lobbyinteressen gut durchsetzen können mit einem kurzen Draht zur Regierung. Und jetzt konnten natürlich auch die Journalisten, Influencer-like, zeigen, dass sie geimpft wurden. Und ich, ja, bin doch etwas verärgert, ob dieser vielen Oberarme, die ich da sehe. Ich kann eigentlich sagen, es gab nur ein geschmackvolles Impffoto. Ich hatte das auch damals gepostet, das war das von Dolly Parton. Ich hab extra ein spezielles Kleid anzog, um dort einen Freiraum zu haben, um geimpft zu werden. Ansonsten ist es eher grässlich. Und ich würde auch sagen, es ist ja jetzt keine Besonderheit mehr, wenn man denn geimpft wird. Es sind ja schon sehr viele geimpft, hoffentlich dann bald wir auch mal. Aber das ist jetzt so ein bisschen, als würde der Diabetiker täglich sich fotografieren, wie er sich Insulin spritzt. Also jetzt sollen wir doch einfach mal zu einer Alltäglichkeit darin erkennen. Und dann kann sich ja jeder noch mal persönlich freuen. Aber muss man das alles auf Twitter, auf Instagram teilen? Also die Influencer natürlich auch. Und es ist auch manchmal erstaunlich, wer da so alles plötzlich in Risikogruppen vorkommt. Ich bin jedenfalls dankbar, dass man sich damals entschieden hat, dass man diese Spritze in den Oberarm gibt und nicht in den Podex. Sonst hätten wir noch ganz andere Bilder.
Ja, und zwar einerseits von den Hinterteilen oder von den Gesichtern währenddessen. Das Selfie hätte noch mal eine neue Qualitätsstufe erreicht, glaube ich.
Stimmt, ja.
Na wer weiß. Ich glaube, das Thema klingt jetzt so langsam aus. Diese Oberarm-Selfies, die du jetzt ansprichst, sind wahrscheinlich die finalen Mitnahmeeffekte aus diesem schönen Medienthema, das wir jetzt so langsam anderthalb Jahre nähert sich hatten. Und ich meine jetzt schon hatten, denn es neigt sich dem Ende. Also ich bin ja bisher um jeden PCR-Test herumgekommen. Und beim Thema Impfen warte ich einfach jetzt bis Juni. Also wenn der Juni da ist, werde ich meinen Hausarzt kontaktieren. Ich bedauere ein bisschen, dass ich wahrscheinlich einen Umweg um die Impfzentren mache, denn diese Experience deutscher Verantwortung, Verwaltung und Verantwortung hätte ich doch gerne noch mal live miterlebt. Da scheint ja wirklich alle drei Meter jemand zu stehen, der die eigentlich 95-jährigen Erstimpflinge da rumführt. Und man öffnet sich dann für die allgemeine Gesellschaft, die noch gut zu Fuß ist und auch Sachen versteht und lesen kann, aber die eben nicht alle drei Meter Hilfe braucht. Aber anscheinend scheint das dort aufrechterhaltend zu sein. Also es bleibt einfach bei einer guten Show, würde ich sagen. Aber ich glaube, ich werde den Hausarzt wählen und werde mich im Juni in der Hoffnung, dass es bei einem einzigen formalen Akt meiner Seite bleibt. Also, dass ich nicht zwei Anläufe brauche für den Impftermin, sondern das ist beim ersten Mal. Weil dann bin ich gut durch die Corona-Pandemie gekommen, ehrlich gesagt. Aber mal gucken, es ist finalisch wie gesagt nach außen.
Wir werden sehen. Ich bin sehr gespannt. Also ich kenne ja nach wie vor ganz, ganz viele über 60-Jährige, die nicht geimpft sind. Auch noch Leute, die wirkliche Risikopatienten sind. Also mit schlimmen, schlimmen Vorerkrankungen, die nicht geimpft sind. Also es hängt wohl auch sehr vom Bundesland ab. Wir in Rheinland-Pfalz sind besonders träge, habe ich den Eindruck. Wir werden schauen. Aber ich verspreche schon mal, wenn ich denn irgendwann geimpft werde, wird es von mir kein Oberarm-Selfie geben.
Gut. Obwohl die Impfung so oft und häufig und degromitiert werden muss, aber es wird weiterhin bei dir bei sieben Unterschriften bleiben und kein Foto.
Ganz genau, das muss doch reichen.
Sehr gut. Wir klingen ja hier noch so ein bisschen den April aus. Es ist ja Mai und wir können ja, da wir Ende Mai wieder zusammensitzen, schon mal überlegen, was könnte im Juni Thema sein oder eben nicht. Matthias, der zum Beispiel die Musik für diesen tollen Podcast hier gemacht hat, hat auf Twitter noch mal darauf hingewiesen, dass der Verlust von Trump und heute, am 15.15 Uhr deutscher Zeit, entscheidet ja das Oversight Board von Facebook, ob Trump noch mal eine Zukunft bei Facebook hat oder nicht. Also wir werden es nicht erfahren, aber wenn ihr es hier hört, dann wird es schon bekannt sein. Und Trump plant ja jetzt eigene Wege. Und Matthias, wie gesagt, wie es auf Twitter noch mal darauf hin, dass die ersten Quartalszahlen jetzt da sind. Wie geht es den Medien ohne Donald Trump? Und CNN hat einen Primetime-Zuschauerverlust in der werberelevanten Zielgruppe von minus 52 Prozent eingefahren. Das leuchtet ein. Wir haben in Deutschland ein Thema, das, klar, Trump hat uns auch beschäftigt, aber wenn man sich die Programmzeitschriften auf Papier, wo auch immer die Rentneruplik unterwegs ist, anschaut, was zum Thema Corona gesendet wird. Alle Nachrichtensendungen, alle Politik-Talkshows und so weiter. Es wird ein Sommer der Umorientierung für den Medienbetrieb. Also wir können uns auf Twitter schon mal gefasst machen auf die ein oder andere, wie soll man sagen, postnatale Pandemie und so weiter.
Ich könnte mir auch vorstellen, dass man jetzt dann wenigstens den Wahlkampf hat. Hätten wir jetzt nicht ein Wahljahr, das so interessant wird dann, auch weil tatsächlich noch ganz viel unklar ist, dann würde man tatsächlich erleben, wie der Journalismus in ein Loch fällt. Dann wäre das Sommerloch, das es ja ohnehin immer gibt, sehr viel größer. Und ich bin da auch sehr gespannt, welche neuen Themen man sich suchen wird. Und sicherlich lassen dann auch Einschaltquoten nach und ist der Nachrichtenkonsum auch ein vollkommen anderer, weil es einen plötzlich nicht mehr so zu betreffen scheint. Also das ist ja natürlich immer ein Scheinargument, dass man sagt, ah, damit habe ich nichts zu tun mit Corona ja schon. Ich muss ja wissen, kann ich jetzt morgen wieder raus oder nicht? Kann ich einkaufen gehen? Andererseits müsste man jetzt endlich mal erkannt haben, das hängt alles mit einem zusammen. Aber ich glaube nicht, dass das passiert, sondern wir werden da eigentlich einen Quotentief erleben. Und es ist ja auch so interessant, dass mit Corona, da ist jeder erlebt, im Umfeld hat irgendwelche anekdotischen Dinge, hat sofort darauf reagieren kann. Und so ist der Unterhaltungsfaktor immer gegeben mit den entsprechenden Protagonisten dann von Streeck bis Lauterbach. Also die ganze Palette ist da und jeder kann sich dazu permanent verhalten. Das ist bei vielen Themen ja nicht so ohne Weiteres möglich. Und da bin ich schon gespannt, wie man damit umgehen wird.
Genau. Corona wird natürlich als Thema nicht ganz verschwinden, nach wem bleiben. Denn, und das ist dann wirklich interessant, es gibt Corona als, so wie du es eben beschrieben hast, Wetterersatzthema. Man kann drüber sprechen, jeder kennt sich aus. Vielleicht ist man nicht konkret betroffen, aber irgendwie dann doch schon und so. Und diese Corona-Geschichte wird aber geschrieben sein. Also man lässt sich, noch ist sie ja offen. Die ganze mediale Kommunikation läuft ja auch unter dem Kalkül, damit es nächste Woche besser wird, damit es in einem Monat besser wird. Wir alle kennen die Zyklen, heute Inzidenz, in drei Wochen Intensivstation und so weiter und so fort. Und ich bin mal sehr gespannt, inwieweit wir uns darauf einlassen, Corona als Thema weiterhin zu behandeln, aber eben nicht mehr unter diesem Gesichtspunkt Geschichte wird geschrieben, sondern Geschichte ist geschrieben. Dass wir uns dann die Impfstrategie nochmal neu anschauen oder auch die soziale Frage, die wir in der April-Ausgabe aufgeworfen haben. Da wird es doch noch einiges zu diskutieren geben, denn rückblickend kann man jetzt schon sagen, auch wenn das natürlich medizinisch absolut notwendig war, so zu impfen, wie wir geimpft haben, aber die ersten 20 Millionen Erstimpflinge hier hatten quasi null Kontakte. Also die haben zum pandemischen Geschehen im Grunde nichts beigetragen wurden, aber aus medizinischen Gründen geschützt. Während jetzt eine Diskussion läuft und da haben wir ja auch aufgrund unserer Thematisierung noch mal einen Hinweis vom Hörer Paul bekommen. Der hat auf ein Tweet von Michaela Mahler hingewiesen, die ihrerseits bei einer Veranstaltung des Studierendenwerks in Berlin zugegen war, wo noch mal sie reportiert. Jetzt kommt hier Sturm auf, aber egal. Zitat, interessant ist auch, dass die Stiko-Empfehlung, Zitat, Menschen, die für das Gemeinwesen besonders relevante Funktionen erfüllen, Zitat Ende, und jetzt Zitat, Personen mit prekären Arbeits- und oder Lebensbedingungen, Zitat Ende, vorgesehen hatte. Letztere wurden vom Gesundheitsministerium dann wieder verworfen. Also wir haben es ja auch mit politischen Entscheidungen zu tun, die tatsächlich ins Eingemachte gehen. Und wir haben ja jetzt gerade eine Diskussion, dass in Köln Chorweiler, weil das über den Tweet von Herrn Böhmermann eben aufsehen erregt wird, dass da jetzt tatsächlich mal ein Impfauto vorgefahren ist, um da einfach jeden, der da einfach sichtbar in den Ruhm weiter war, zu impfen.
Mit wohlgrägem Interesse, also nicht das, was die ganze Zeit so immer wieder mal von der Bildzeitung insinuiert wurde. Na ja, die mit Migrationshintergrund, die wollen sich auch gar nicht impfen lassen. Die sind ja eh skeptisch gegenüber dem Staat, Stichwort Parallelgesellschaften. All das stimmt nicht. Die standen Schlange.
Genau, die standen Schlange. Solche Aktionen wird es jetzt wahrscheinlich häufiger geben. Aus guten Gründen, weil das wirklich einen Effekt auf pandemische... Also, das ist pandemisches Impfen, nicht das medizinische. Die sind da nicht vom Tode bedroht. Aber wir haben die ganze Gesellschaft runtergefahren, um die, die vom Tode bedroht sind, da zu schützen. Und da gehören die natürlich vorgängig dazu. Denn die haben auch alle Kinder, die gehen in Schulen. Und in den Schulen arbeiten sehr alte Leute. Und wir haben erst jetzt wieder Schulschließungen flächendeckend bekommen. Na ja, eine Sache, auch als Nachtrag noch, bevor wir hier in den Salon einsteigen. Christine Urspruch, kennst du sie? Schauspielerin. Schauspielerin, genau. Ich kenn sie natürlich nicht, weil ich hab noch nie einen Münstertatort gesehen. Es kam aber jetzt ein Münstertatort. Das heißt, jetzt fällt mal wieder alles zusammen. Ein vor Monaten abgedrehter Tatort wurde jetzt gesendet. Und sehr viele Zuschauer waren er picht darauf zu erfahren, ob noch irgendwas zu Corona von Jan-Josef lief.
Ja. Und Jan-Josef lief. Er sagte, das sei ein starkes Statement, dass das 14 Millionen Menschen sich angesehen hat.
Für mich ist das eher... Es ist jetzt alles politisch?
eine persönliche Bankotterklärung, wenn man sich den Tatort ansieht. Aber na ja, jedenfalls ist das schon eine eigenartige Politisierung, die er da vornimmt.
Genau. Die Christine Urspruch ist Krimikollegin. Also sie spielt an Jan-Josef Liefers Seite, wohl irgendwie so im Labor, keine Ahnung. Das macht ja da so den Laborarzt. Und bei Bild hat sie Zitate abgeliefert, die ich als Wortspende bei Tionline nachgelesen habe und die wie folgt lauten. Sie wurde nämlich dann gefragt, was halten Sie denn von der Aktion vom Jan? Und dann hat sie gesagt, ach, das ist schwierig. Aber man muss ehrlich sagen, der ist leider nach hinten losgegangen. Also der versucht, das über diese 53 Videos da alles ein bisschen aufzulockern. Niemand wollte diesen unglücklichen Zuspruch von rechts oder sich in eine Querdenkerecke stellen lassen. Sie sagt also, es ist schon mein guter Kumpel, über den ich hier rede, aber die Aktion war nicht so dufte. Also eigentlich nicht so richtig Futter für die Bild. Sie hätte da gerne Krawall gesehen, deswegen hat sie sie interviewt. Aber sie schiebt noch nach, und das fand ich dann wirklich ein bisschen bedenklich, zu ihrer eigenen Situation. Es ist schon schwierig, das muss ich zugeben. Ich bekomme gerade keinerlei Hilfe und habe auch keinen Anspruch auf Arbeitslosengeld, weil ich in 36 Monaten nicht lange genug am Stück fest angestellt war. Wenn in Deutschland sogar Tatort-Schauspielerinnen unter Corona leiden, dann muss man sich wirklich fragen, was unterhalb dieser absoluten glänzenden Spitze des Eisbergs los ist. Ich habe diese Veranstaltung mit Merkel und den Künstlern noch nicht gesehen. Ich habe aber Serra Somuncu's Podcastaufarbeitung, die er kurz gemacht hat, dazu gehört. Es ist wirklich erschütternd. Ich will es ja nur noch mal kurz zu Protokoll geben. Die Lage von Kunst und Kultur in Deutschland ist wirklich erschütternd. Es gibt einen guten Clip in der BBC. Den werde ich dann irgendwann machen, wenn wir wieder politikfreiem Fernsehpodcast machen spielen. Aber Künstlerinnen in England sind mittlerweile der Ansicht, wenn Politiker selber nicht ins Museum gehen, ins Kino, wo auch immer hin, wenn einfach nur einmal im Jahr die Wagner-Festspiele sind und so weiter.
Genau, da sieht man ja dann auch mal Merkel.
Blenden die es einfach aus. Dann blenden die es einfach aus. Kann man in Großbritannien besonders deutlich sehen, da brennt ja Boris Johnson alles aus. Selbst Wales-Wales-Unabhängigkeit wird ausgeblendet. Schottland wählt jetzt im Mai. Worte von ihm werden ausgeblendet. Die New-Nord-Örland-Frage hat er bis heute noch nicht verstanden. Und genauso gehen die auch mit Kultur um. Also wer sich überlegt, was kann ich aus der Corona-Krise jetzt für mich lernen, so wie die Politik mit Corona umgegangen ist und allen Folgeeffekten, ist es der allgemeine Umgang von Politik mit Themen, würde ich sagen. Und die Kultur hat es leider schlecht erwischt, da Aufmerksamkeit fehlt.
Genau, und das geht nur unter dem Aspekt der Kreativwirtschaft. Dann sind die natürlich alle mal irgendwie da und versuchen das ein oder andere zu versprechen. Und die Kultur macht ja dann auch die Stadt attraktiv. Also beispielsweise macht es Frankfurt attraktiv, dass diese Stadt das beste Opernhaus von Deutschland hat, schon häufiger gekürt wurden. Und ich würde auch sagen, es ist ein exzellentes Haus. Und das trägt alles dazu bei, dass zum Beispiel die Mieten ganz nach oben gehen, weil Frankfurt damit eine sehr attraktive Stadt wird. Aber das ist wirklich eine ganz, ganz desolate Situation, dass wir eigentlich sehr kulturferne Politiker haben, bis auf wenige Ausnahmen. Also früher gab es die Oberbürgermeisterin Petra Roth in Frankfurt, die sehr kulturaffin war und die man auch bei solchen Veranstaltungen dann mal gesehen hat. Aber die meisten Politiker sieht man wirklich nur, wenn irgendwas gefeiert werden muss, wenn irgendwo eine Rede gehalten werden muss. Aber so privat sieht man Politiker nicht in Kulturveranstaltungen. Und das zeigt sich hier sehr, sehr deutlich. Und das ist so besorgniserregend eigentlich. Und dass man da auch noch immer keine vernünftigen Zusagen dann macht, auch wenn das ja gar nicht viel kosten würde. Ja, das würde man ja auch mal ein bisschen mal durchrechnen können, was man für manche Konzerne ausgegeben hat und was die Kultur dann so kostet, um sie am Leben zu halten. Das ist ja wenig. Also auch die Kulturausgaben sind ja sehr gering.
Ja, wir werden uns die Renaissance der Kultur wahrscheinlich dann ab Mai hoffentlich mit erlebbaren, thematisierbaren, wirklichen Effekten, Phänomenen, keine Ahnung. Die Projekte gehen ja dann hoffentlich irgendwann los. Die ersten Privilegien. Söder hat ja für Mai jetzt ausgerufen, dass man in Bayern seine Grundrechte zurückkriegt als Geimpfter. Und zwar vollständig. Und ich bin mal gespannt. Klar, die Angebote sind noch nicht da. Also man kann jetzt mit dem Privileg ins Ressent zu gehen. Nicht viel machen, weil die Ressenten ja trotzdem zu. Aber vielleicht geht das ja dann doch alles ziemlich schnell. Ich bin jedenfalls von diesem Impf-Fortschritt mehr als eine halbe Million jetzt am Tag im 7-Tageschnitt. Das ist schon beachtlich, denn damit kommt man recht zügig auf diese 40, 50 Prozent Werte, die ja dann in Israel und England schon Effekte zeigen. Deutschland jetzt weniger als 5000 Intensivpatienten und in England noch ein Todesfall pro Tag.
Ja, aber es hätte auch alles schneller gehen können. Wir sind jetzt auch natürlich so erschlagen von den Schreckensmeldungen, dass wir jetzt danach gieren, was Positives zu bekommen. Und das ist ja auch vollkommen okay. Bei manchen habe ich ein bisschen den Eindruck, es ist eher schon so ein Stockholm-Syndrom. Man will gar nicht, dass es einen Fortschritt gibt. Und da habe ich mir auch schon ein Kunstprojekt überlegt. Wie wäre das eigentlich, wenn man so eine Art Disneyland baut für Corona? Also so ein Corona-Disneyland. Und dort kann täglich modelliert werden. Da können Ausgangssperren eingehalten werden. Da könnte man jeden Abend eine Talkshow machen, wo man noch mal sagt, wenn wir jetzt nicht mit den Zahlen direkt runtergehen, dann kann ich Ihnen in zwei bis drei Wochen sagen. Also ich glaube, da wäre noch mal ganz viel möglich. Und da könnte ich mir auch sehr viele Fernsehmoderatoren vorstellen, die dort allabendlich durchmoderieren. Und man macht einfach so ein kleines Corona-Disneyland für all die, die sagen, ich hab noch nicht genug nach 14 Monaten.
Ja, es gibt ja in manchen Freizeitparks...
Das war jetzt zynisch, da muss man jetzt aufpassen, nicht, dass ich jetzt da auch einen auf den Deckel bekomme.
Es gibt ja in manchen Freizeitparks die Räume, wo man sich noch mal wie ein Kind fühlen kann, wo die Tische 2, 30 Meter hoch sind.
Oder eine Westernstadt oder sowas.
Genau, und so kann man das ja auch als Lockdown-Land mal kurz machen. Überall stehen Plexiglass-Schilder und man darf nicht mit Bargeld bezahlen und man darf sich nicht berühren. Man muss alleine durchgehen.
Ich bin ja sehr gespannt, aber das wird immer wieder Thema werden in Podcasts hier. Wie sich dann doch vielleicht unser Verhalten etwas geändert hat. Oder werden wir zum Beispiel, wenn wir jetzt mal wirklich durch sind, also wenn wir sagen, jetzt ist Corona besiegt weltweit, also sagen wir mal im Herbst 2022, wenn alles durchgeimpft ist und wir können dann sagen, es ist vollbracht, wird sich dann aber doch das ein oder andere halten? Also wird man vielleicht sagen, im November, Dezember, wenn die Krippewelle so anrollt, dass man sagt, na ja, jetzt U-Bahn fahren, wie früher immer, wo alles geschnief, gehustet hat, da fahre ich doch lieber mit FFP2 Maske. Oder wenn man erkältet ist, dass man sagt, ich trage meine FFP2 Maske, ich muss jetzt nicht jemanden im Einzelhandel anstecken, nur weil ich jetzt trotzdem was einkaufen gehen will. Also wird da eine gewisse Sensibilität vielleicht doch kommen. Das könnte ich mir gut vorstellen und fände das gar nicht so schlecht.
Ja, wir müssen den Corona-Schleier da mal lüften und feststellen, ah, wir haben auch die Grippewelle beendet. Das können wir ja jedes Jahr machen. Also das spricht ja nichts dagegen. Einfach mal im Herbst für ein paar Wochen die Maske wirklich auf, wenn wir zwischen Unbekannten im Nahverkehr sitzen. Also ich glaube, da wird es Nach-Effekte geben, die bleiben. Was Strukturwandel bedeuten kann, das lesen wir ja gleich im Salon. Wir teasern kurz an, wir lesen ausgeliefert. Das Buch hätte auch ausgezerrt oder sonst wie heißen können. Alec McGillis, von George Packer gelobt, aber einer der besten Reporter Amerikas. George Packer ist ja selber ein guter. Er hat also ein Buch über Amerika nach oder mit Amazon geschrieben. Und es ist schlimm. Um das mal so anzuteasern, ist es wirklich schlimm. Ist allerdings auch eine gute Vorbereitung. Wir lesen ja nächstes Mal, haben wir schon entschieden, Klobuchar's Antitrust Buch. Das ist wahrscheinlich genau die politische Komponente, die dann in diesem Buch hier filmt. Ich werde danach kurz auf die beiden Nomics zu sprechen kommen. Denn jetzt werden so langsam die ersten Grundlagentexte zu dem, also alle waren erst mal überrascht, was passiert an Amerika. Aber jetzt kommen so langsam die ersten Einschätzungen. Dann habe ich ein Buch über die Tarzanökonomie gelesen, geschrieben vom Chefökonom von Spotify, der nämlich dem Unternehmen beibrachte, wie man innerhalb der Musikindustrie sich wirtschaftlich nach vorne schwingt, vom Baum zu Baum. Aber die Liane, die einen eben noch so gut nach vorne brachte, muss man dann wirklich mal loslassen, wenn man die nächste schon im Griff hat. Also das ist ein wunderbarer Titel und das Buch ist super interessant. Dann was Kurzes zum Lieferkettengesetz. Und was wäre, wenn Corona in den 60ern passiert wäre?
Tja, ich blicke auch aufs Management mit Johann Chaputot. Gehorsam macht frei heißt sein Buch. Eine kurze Geschichte des Managements von Hitler bis heute. Das ist ein provokanter Titel. Provokant ist auch dieses Buch. Denn eine These oder die Hauptthese ist dieses Management mit ja macht einfach mal, legt mal los. Verlasst euch nicht immer nur auf die Hierarchien. Wir brauchen zwar klare Ansagen, aber dann habt ihr Freiheiten. Ganz viele solcher Paradigmen, die gab es im Nationalsozialismus. Die sind da entwickelt worden. Da wird die Karriere eines Management-Gurus nachgezeichnet. In diesem Buch sehr interessant. Dann geht es um Petfluencer. Nämlich Tiere sind ganz, ganz wichtig für das Marketing geworden. Außerdem ein herausragender Text von Adam Toose. Ein sehr, sehr langer Essay, mit dem wir die beiden Nomics verstehen, mit dem wir aber vielleicht auch noch viel mehr verstehen. Und wir können uns mal fragen, ob wir sowas vielleicht dann auch in Deutschland erleben werden. Nämlich, er hat sich ganz mit Paul Krugman beschäftigt, mit dem Ökonom und dessen Entwicklung in den vergangenen Jahrzehnten bis heute. Und dann gibt es noch etwas über eine Sängerin, die noch mal dasselbe Album aufnimmt.
Ist es ein Jazz-Album? Super knifflig. Okay, sehr gut. Dann sind wir alle gespannt. Wir verabschieden uns hier von der Allgemeinheit und gehen zu unseren Salonisten. Wir warten, glaube ich, diesen Monat auf den 2222. Um es mal zu projektieren. Gut, also an diese 2200.
Bis gleich.